with Georgia's president mr. Marvel
Asheville Ian attendants the Strasbourg
plenary saw an historic association
agreement seared between Georgia and the
EU although the Georgian justice system
remains too closely tied to political
power this country in the Caucasus has
succeeded in making wide-ranging
democratic reforms away this new
agreement Georgia is is gaining new
tools of integration of reforms as well
as of integration into European
structures for nearly 20 years Georgia
has been turning West opinion polls show
that nearly seventy percent of Georgians
approve of the agreement with the EU
giorgia is European country giorgia is
the crandall one of them of European
civilization giorgia have to move closer
to the European Union it is important
number one for all the Georgian people
will we one day see Georgia become a
member of the EU if so the road will be
long in any case as there's no plan for
EU enlargement in the next five years
plenary saw an emotional display from
spanish mep xavier coooo so poorly as he
brandished photos taken recently in
Venezuela they showed violations of
human rights including brutal beatings
of the opposition to President Maduro in
2014 more than 3,000 people were
arrested for political activism nicest
elevators prision no hiciste y de pedir
poder judicial assistant torturous
concrete a--'s todos preguntamos que
hasta cuando se arma drove a bus are de
rosa paciencia mi piece made a resolute
political gesture by voting through a
resolution the goal to end human rights
violations this week MEP s unlocked a
massive 126 million seven hundred and
twenty 4968 euros to help regions struck
by serious natural disasters at the end
of 2013 and well into 2014 it was above
all flooding which week to havoc across
the continent some victims will receive
funding ranging from 3.7 million euros
for Greece to 60 million euros for
Serbia the EU solidarity fund was
created in reaction to the severe floods
in central europe in the summer of two
thousand and two so far 24 european
countries have been supported with over
3.7 billion euros